today we're going to talk about
was beyond the basic education
college degree into the world of
lifelong learning in the past with a
good education under your belt you could
hope that your employer would take
responsibility for providing more
training and ongoing education but in
today's world of work there's less
training that's provided by employers so
it's more important for individuals to
think about what they need to do to take
care of their lifelong learning needs
that means you have to have a strategy
so let's start with those in high school
in high school the message that we
emphasize is that it's important to stay
in school to work hard to graduate in
good standing nothing is more important
than that if you can while you are in
high school get internships co-op jobs
part-time jobs in the summer or even
during the school year if that's
possible so that you can begin to see
what the world of work is like maybe you
can meet some people who are good role
models in the workplace maybe you can
test whether you are really interested
in one kind of a job or another maybe
you can get some technical skills that
will help you identify what you really
are good at let me give you the advice
of dr. James FICO an industrial
psychologist who works with employers to
match good talented young people with
the jobs that are available
dr. FICO says there are plenty of good
jobs in my sectors manufacturing and law
enforcement retirements are creating
lots of opportunities employers expect
much more of their employees today that
at anytime in my memory they want
technical skills and they want a much
higher caliber of job readiness and
character students best bet is to find
mentors for whom they can learn from
over a longer period of time and
employers want a great deal of the
following they want courage they want
integrity they want a devotion to the
job and a commitment to really doing a
great job they want a vision for the
future of what the work might look like
they want a commitment to working in
teams and yes of course they want tech
competence the first four of these are
the most desired and maybe the hardest
to find according to dr. fecal
regardless of the age of the applicant
but then he goes on to say that I find
that the most critical language of the
workplace today is the language of math
a thorough knowledge of arithmetic he
says yes he means basic math algebra
geometry basic adding and subtracting
would do more for business success than
any other single discipline outside of
the character features mentioned earlier
remember that the best mathematicians in
the United States led us into this
recession a few years ago because they
didn't understand the numbers that they
were working with and how to really
calculate risk what about those of you
who are going to go on for technical
degrees in community colleges after high
school well here the key from all kinds
of research in evidence is that the most
important thing to do is to look for
programs that are well linked to the
employers in your region and in the
industry you want to work in employers
working with community colleges and
vocational schools designing the
curriculum together providing advice and
mentoring for students and then helping
to make sure that the the skills that
are being taught are the modern skills
needed on the job the second feature is
to make sure that these programs that
you choose mix classroom experience in
teaching with on-the-job opportunities
to apply those skills and to see the
relevance of the the material that you
are learning in the classroom the first
hand the third feature of a successful
community college and vocational school
is that they have success in placing
graduates not only in that first job but
with employers who have career pathways
that is job ladders that allow people to
continue to learn and to advance over
time and maybe to come back for
refresher courses as needed how about
college graduates and college students
well the thing to do here is to make
sure again like in high school one
gained
experience while in school looking for
those summer internships or co-op
placements in schools that provide that
so that you can really start to build
your professional network while you're
still in school and again test whether
you are really well-suited for different
kinds of jobs then it's important to
seek out mentors on your first job the
evidence is very clear that having a
supervisor or a mentor from somewhere
else in the organization that helps you
learn the ropes and can then vouch for
you for other jobs as they come along is
really critical to their future success
in that organization it's important that
you pursue outside educational
opportunities take advantage of all the
universities like MIT and other great
schools that are now providing online
learning opportunities so that you can
deepen your knowledge and broaden out
your professional base over time it's
also important that you maintain your
professional networks and your contacts
over time make sure that you are
interacting with your peers ask your
employers to make sure that you have
opportunities to go to professional
medians and do stay current in what is
going on and build those networks so
that you have others who are sharing the
same experiences and you are learning
together and then finally it's always
important to keep that resume up-to-date
keep one foot in the external labor
market because you never know when you
will have to draw on it for looking for
your next opportunity so I believe we
are in a world where lifelong learning
now becomes critical to long-term career
success start by picking an occupation a
profession that is of interest to you
and then keep working on your career
over time testing yourself am I staying
current can I find a job in my
profession outside of my current
employer and do I keep my network strong
and up-to-date so that I can draw on the
assistance of other people as needed
you